hello reject nation Greg Alba here and
I'm John we are the most qualified
people to watch the red band trailer for
Super Troopers to because John and I
have not seen this movie yet but let us
justify our presence here for a second
that movie was not a huge hit and got a
big following over time yeah so if
they're making a sequel and they wanted
to make money you need to have a trailer
that will make you want to go watch the
first one and didn't work out so well
for Blade Runner 2049 that might work
out okay for Super Troopers to 100
million opening weekend but guys it's
Saturday and we got an announcement to
make because of today's video sponsor
because something special happening
tomorrow now this is a little different
we talked about it yesterday but it's
very exciting stuff recently we
partnered with draftkings to bring you
an NFL showdown contest just in time for
playoffs so what this means is John I
like it when you tell them what it means
telling what it means well it means Greg
you could win up to $50,000 that is five
more dollars than I currently possess
homeboy in my venmo the cavity all those
times I paid for other people's dinners
and they said they've been momi here's
how it works you draft four offensive
players and two defensive players and
then you just start letting the points
roll in put together a great lineup and
you could walk away a little better than
you started and with a $5 deposit this
contest is 100% free that's right free
did you say free yes free free yes we
did this bit yesterday so make sure to
get your lineups and by Sunday January
21st that is tomorrow 6:40 p.m. Eastern
Time 3:40 p.m. Pacific Standard Time so
click that link in the description box
to sign up today people and patron of
the day shout out for David gun day
they've been waiting for a second chance
[Music]
[Music]
it turns out the French Canadian town
same George Jr rock is actually on
American soil
you'll be phasing out a Canadian mounted
unit you wouldn't need a ladder
[Music]
famous people
[Music]
neither of you speak English I did we
would like to eat your paper can you
show me your paper
what did you say do you want to leader :
it's pretty awesome
[Laughter]
I wonder they improvised that I know
what I'm doing 4:20 this movie clearly
knows its audience right here you gotta
give a movie credit from knowing what
it's for I'm going completely sober that
day yes that's what I do on 4/20 I do
not drive and get high because you can
get a DUI according to all the freeway
signs in LA now I'm catching up to the
alcohol game yeah I think it's about
time we watch Super Troopers I guess so
if we want maybe we can do a patreon
reaction on it full length going on yeah
join us and we will not be high no we're
gonna be so far so sober sober sober so
be yourself I don't know when it comes
to sequels like this when you get such a
cult following especially for a comedy
or a movies bigger than the box office
numbers represent the sequel nine times
that attended because this looks funny
and amusing to me yeah but I'm kind of
worried to watch Super Troopers fresh
like even if we watch it now it'll still
be pretty fresh in my mind by the time
this movie comes out so there's a part
of my brain going so just avoid it
because because I feel like about watch
Super Troopers 1 and really like it
odds are I probably justified with the
sequel because a lot of times the
sequels are just not as funny anchorman
2 people like wet hot American summer
the Netflix 1 but even but I guess it's
a different format now and that's a
whole team and that troupe has worked
together a whole bunch
so this might work better for people who
haven't seen Super Troopers in a long
time see as I don't know if they're just
repeating jokes or anything I doesn't
seem like they are and then get the
feeling I'm like oh this would be funny
if I saw the first movie like I didn't
get any of those jokes in here not too
much yeah there were there a couple
moments where I wondered if maybe there
was a double meaning but usually
everything seemed like a joke for
everybody the same yeah when it comes to
especially sequels for stoner gross-out
you know
slaps you know wacky comedies like this
dog answered yeah with with being
highbrow every time just sort of comes
down to like is this batch of jokes
funny yeah yeah I don't know I mean this
trailer did amuse me like it you know
III get sort of the basic idea of what
the charm of this is and watching it you
know for that I was like this looks
pretty fun and you know what we probably
an oculus what I'm thinking what we
could do is do a full-length spoiler
review of Super Troopers - when it comes
out and break down every joke all the
Easter all the ease that the references
to the first they might share it because
you know that if this works Grandma's
Boy - is gonna be right I haven't seen
Super Troopers but here's what I know
they gotta cross it over with Starship
Troopers and when you when you really
want to go crazy you cross it over would
vr troopers this show i watch when I was
a little kid oh yeah does anything with
trooper and this sounds like a good good
mixture it sounds like a there you go
there's there's a review I mean there's
gonna be a whole lot of easy Canadian
jokes and I'm sure a lot of like dudes
getting close to each other and making
that uncomfortable and then like weird
gross out scenarios and it's probably
you know gay jokes are David Gandy it's
your shout out today buddy David Gandy I
know you're going through a rather tough
period right now you know what I just
wanted to tell you that to us you are
our super trooper not the Highway Patrol
officer type like a life super trooper
you battled almost a battle therapy you
battled cancer therapy all those things
you made it out on the other end of your
you're obviously a good soul we've
Google hanging out with you and you're
just a really kind-hearted soul and
you're very generous your artistic
intelligent I bet that you get so many
he's and he's an older white guy but I
bet he gets like so many hot black
chicks I bet you're like a Robert DeNiro
man that's just the vibe you exude you
know that exactly that's how I wouldn't
because he's so quiet in a glance he's
so quiet and calm and I imagine he has
like some really hot ass black
girlfriend guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects officially click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is out hey people
click that link in the description box
to win enter that contest
yeah automatically pick a chance to win
just for sake that's not true don't
don't